en parlant des pit francis grignon hymne
beyoncé elle a dernièrement fait un nom
de 6 millions de dollars 6,9 beyoncé à
des organisations américaines pour
lutter contre le coronavirus elle en a
expliqué les raisons sur son site
internet
je vous le dis voilà 6 millions de
dollars voilà donc ça fait partie est ce
que voilà parce qu'on n'a pas eu la vie
de benji mine de rien oui le béret et
rabat trouver des cons qu'ils vont dire
avoir une sensation à les milliardaires
donc elle peut donner 6 millions et ben
non excusez-moi il faut saluer les
gestes de tous ceux qui donnent que soit
5 euros 10 euros 1000 euros 6 millions
d'euros ça me rend dingue ces discours
là robben j'ai franchement c'est une
ronde web beyoncé elle a beaucoup
d'argent mais elle fait un chèque de
sima mon pote aller là-bas alors avoir
été abaissés 90 et 100 millions d'euros
donc moi je trouve ça pas bien alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait on donne pas et on
vous reproche de pas donner on vous vous
donnait on vous reproche d'avoir dit que
vous avez donnée et aulas et nous avons
fait au fait où on fait des choses et en
plus il ya des tables sont qui donne moi
j'ai appris ça il ya récemment il ya
plein de gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
noms qui donnent aux hôpitaux qui était
à arrêter de trouver tout suspect
suspicieux voilà on peut faire des
choses normalement sans qu'on ait on le
fasse par intérêt arrêter avec ça c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable et un
jour qu'est ce qui va se passer
eh bien les gens ils donneront plus ils
vont se barrer et on leur dira bailly
son parti bah oui son parti vous leur
avez craché dessus et ben voila moi ça
m'énerve
bah voilà le forcené a poussé son il
fonctionne alors oui il est forcené